J’entends la mer ! Ça fait du bien…
Une vraie « capsule de déconfiné ».
Et pourtant, elle n’est pas tout près.
A vol d’oiseau, au moins 200 km.
En fait, nous entendons le son de notre corps.
Plus précisément,
celui du sang qui circule dans nos vaisseaux.
Le coquillage fait caisse de résonance.
Quand il est plaqué sur l’oreille,
il récupère le son qui se propage dans le conduit auditif.
Les ondes rebondissent sur les parois solides
du coquillage et le son est amplifié.
Si on reste immobile, on entend un bruit de fond.
Mais si on bouge légèrement le coquillage,
on obtient une variation qui évoque
le bruit des vagues dans le lointain.
Entre nous ça marche aussi très bien
avec une boite de maquereaux.
Même avec un pot de confiture.
Je vous promets, je n’entends pas le chant des fraises.
Enfin quand même, avec celui-ci,
ça marche drôlement bien !
Normal, c’est marée haute !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n’hésitez pas à la noyer sous les pouces bleus.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles
des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en publie une nouvelle chaque jour.
Pour éviter d’en louper,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.